[Music]
hi I'm Julie hello I'm destiny today
we're going to tackle a very important
issue tell us okay we volunteered to do
this because we stain ourselves all the
time and we know if you're watching this
video that you do too we wanted to get
to the bottom of the mystery do stain
remover pens work and if they do which
one is best
so this innate when was the last time
you stained your clothes this morning
people who know me know that I'm like
very clumsy I fall down the stairs
I fall up the stairs and usually when
those things happen I usually have
something in my hand
coffee bagel spaghetti it's always like
someone else telling me like you got a
little something today I'm going to
stain myself on purpose to see which
instant stain remover works best let's
do this
[Music]
I have four stain removers to choose
from today let's see the first one and
see how it works let's do it
whip whip it I've never heard of whip it
I've never heard of whip it either I
like the name so I'm hoping it's a
winner I think you just like my thought
wait a bit over so the Direction's just
say remove excess residue apply brush
tip to stain seems pretty
straightforward it smells really potent
it smells like cleaning some like I'm in
school and I'm like coloring it's kind
of helping it's like lifting some of
that uh tomato we read it's working kind
of verdicts still out in my book oh I
think it's coming out and I'm just not
aware of it so with it what did you
think did you did it work for you it got
some of it out I mean it's still
obviously like red but less red so far
mine I kind of focused on like cut a
line through and it's kind of like
looking a lot lighter it's not like pure
white but it's pretty close all right
let's see stain remover number two Thank
You Santa dry out on the go a hundred go
I've never heard of this just first
looking at it I'm assuming they're like
targeting it for more like kind of
sensitive material just cuz it says in
big letters safe for special care
clothes so let's go for it so it just
says remove excess residue from the
stain while squeezing pen you scrubber
like an eraser to eliminate stain oh you
squeeze this one that's kind of cool oh
yeah oh oh yeah try yo I'm already into
it oh this is actually getting it out
dry out of it like yeah dry l's the jam
I don't know if you know about this guy
I oh where can I find that do you guys
know about dry oh this is like awesome
honest taking the cake it's taking it
out like immediately dry out you got me
you get me dry l I'm a fan I'm sold dry
L so far I mean out of the two we've
tried dry L is the jam so if you can see
that was whip it right here and then
next to it dry out so it's like already
just like instantly
it is all right dry out so far you're in
the lead let's see if the other two
stain removers can catch up so what do
we got next destiny we got some good old
trusty tide to go pens I feel like
they're the ones that started it I feel
like they are too like my first time
hearing about instant stain remover was
the tide to go bad either they were the
first or they got great marketing but
there are probably the only ones that I
know of by name do you think it's gonna
work here's the real test I don't know
we'll see I always smell that I'm not
sure why maybe this is why you're so
clumsy maybe there are too many
chemicals and this is like one of my
thickest stain so let's see if tied see
what you got Oh kind of like have to
press down and then like the tide listen
the tae [ __ ] side it's already Wow yeah
Wow I was feeling really loyal to dry L
but I don't know they're both like kind
of in a dead heat for me I can see why
dry L they're like marketing was like
for sensitive clothes like you don't
have to try hard on your fabric to like
get it out I don't know it's working
really well dry l might still be funny
thinking try o like a cool second let's
try the last one I mean you know what I
was wrong when I said that the tide to
go pens were the only ones I've heard of
cuz I have heard of shout I didn't know
they came in wipes I really seen that
before
wipe seemed like pretty convenient -
yeah wiping go treat stains shortly
after they occur lucky for you they just
occurred there she goes
sniffing more chemicals listen I'm just
curious okay oh not bad oh I like this I
like that it's like soapy and like
really um moist I feel like it could
really get stayed out I mean I feel like
some of the Pens were kind of hard to
work with so I get why someone might
want a wife instead when I spell
something my first instinct is to grab
like a paper towel wet it and then I'm
like so I like I feel like this is what
that would be great for oh this just
working really well actually
hey Shou I hear you shouting at me
okay I hear you I'm not shouting with
joy over this shout I feel like mine is
really coming out I thought this kind of
like a little bit more like work
especially this quilt if you're sure
that's true
oh well yeah that's true if you're like
wearing it it's probably not standing
mature it's I'm winning shouts we're
looking really well for me all right
let's see I gotta tell you the downside
with the wipes is now your hands have
like the chemicals destiny is sniffing
all over them but also it did help lift
I will say it helps lift better than
some of the other ones that we used so
here's the show and I I think it got it
out really well I mean pretty well in
comparison it's a dead heat for first
place in my book between Shou and dry L
this is the dry L personally I think
this one worked the best the shot was a
close second um but this just really as
soon as I got in there to started the
listing and I liked the way it smelled
the smell test all that matters to me
they're gonna smell good which was your
favorite so my personal favorite was the
dry L when I want to remove a stain I
want to be like mediate and like
effective and I think dry L did the best
job after dry L I think the shout wipes
did a pretty good job I think the tide
to go pen would be next and then the
Whippet also did not really do a great
job of lifting the same I feel the exact
same way in your ranking system the last
three actually we're all pretty good but
between Shou and dry L they both worked
pretty well but there's dry out it's
just easier to use it comes out easier
if you're killing the game drying trails
the way to go Catania I'm just I'm proud
of you and I'm proud of us yeah for
solving the world's greatest issue I'm
so happy that we got to the bottom of
the century dry LZ Anson
[Music]